what up space fam golson here for anime
uproar
and i'm here with one of the most
daunting projects i've ever undertaken
i said that if you guys showed enough
interest and we got enough likes on the
all
zone users video that i'd make this one
and the feedback was amazing we already
got over 400
000 views on that video and over 8 000
likes
i was resisting making this video
because there are so many paramecia
fruits
but i decided to just bite the bullet
because you guys earned it
i will however split it up in parts
since there are so many to cover
if you want to see the next part part 2
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know
and share this video with a friend if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss out
on new one-piece videos when they drop
i'll bring them up again
at the end of the video but i want to
give a quick thank you to our glorious
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive youtube issues and make videos
like this one possible keep in mind
there will be manga spoilers in this
video
in this series i will be covering all
canon paramecia fruits
that were in the original manga you've
been warned now without further ado
let's jump into it paramecia fruits can
best be described by what they are not
they are not logia fruits that allow
their users to transform into natural
elements
and they are not zoned fruits that allow
their users to transform into animals
i'm obviously oversimplifying here and
you can check out my video on logia
fruits and zone fruits to learn more
about them
but that's the gist of it if a fruit
doesn't fit into those two categories
then it's gonna be a paramecia fruit
as with the other devil fruits the user
loses the ability to swim the best way
to get a sense of them is to just
jump into specific examples so let's do
that keep in mind i won't be going into
these fruits in a lot of detail because
there are so many
if you want to see one explored further
let me know in the comments and i can
make a dedicated video on it let's start
with luffy and his gomu gomu no me aka
gum gum fruit
this fruit turns the user into a rubber
human their body becomes like rubber
letting them stretch this fruit lets
luffy send back bullets cannonballs and
even makes him resistant to blunt
attacks
because rubber is a natural insulator
luffy is immune to electric attacks and
can even land attacks on inel
the rumble rumble fruit user without
haki because of the electric nature
of the latter's powers we know that
luffy can also use his powers to bounce
and inflate his body parts luffy can use
his devil through power to enter into
his unique forms called gears
we won't get into them too much here but
their second gear which speeds up his
blood flow
and turns his skin pink there's third
gear where he blows into his rubber
bones which
drastically increases the mass and
strength of the affected limbs
and there's fourth gear which combines
blowing air into his body and hockey
this last form focuses on making the
upper body specifically more muscular
and powerful
it pretty much lets him use the speed
associated with his second gear
and the strength associated with his
third gear we'll leave it at that for
the purpose of this video
but you can let me know if you want a
whole video dedicated to luffy's gears
in the comments below
next we have buggy and his bada bada no
me
aka chop chop fruit this fruit turns the
user into a splitting human a splitting
human is immune from cuts
it's like the opposite of luffy if
anyone tries to cut
buggy his body parts will be sliced but
he'll still be alive
and he'll still be able to control his
separate body parts he can even split
his body parts up himself if he isn't
cut
this ability lets parts of buggy's body
levitate breaking the rules of gravity
he can even lift heavy people and carry
them in the air like jinbe
there are limitations though his feet do
not fly and his separated body parts
cannot function
if they don't remain within the
affective area his split up body parts
can still feel pain which can be a real
problem
as illustrated when luffy kicked the
clown in the groin
next we have iron mace alvida and the
subasu
no me aka slip slip or smooth smooth
fruit
as the name suggests the fruit makes the
user's skin smooth and slippery as a
result
most attacks will slide off the user's
body interestingly enough if the user
has any excess fat
it will slip off as we saw with alvida
and they'll become thin
and the best thing about the power is
that the user can take their shoes off
and slide around
as if they were skating next we have mr
five and his bom um
no me aka bom bom fruit the fruit makes
the user a bomb human
and lets them make any part of their
body including mucus or hair
explode the user experiences no harm
from the explosions
in conclusion picking your nose has
never been so deadly
next we have miss valentine and her kilo
kilo no me aka kilo kilo fruit
this is a very interesting power the
size of the user's body remains the same
but they can change the weight of it
from 1 to 10
000 kilograms so they can choose to be
light enough to float in the wind with
an umbrella or heavy enough to crush an
opponent
the user appears to be able to move
normally despite the change in weight
you gotta admit miss valentine looks
good for a woman who sometimes weighs 22
046 pounds next up we have our precious
nico robin and her hanahanna no me aka
flower flower fruit
this fruit lets robin sprout extra body
parts from any nearby surface
after the time skip she can sprout up to
1 000 body parts at once and she can
even produce a full body clone of
herself
she can sprout just eyes or ears which
makes this power great for espionage
purposes
like buggy there's an effective range
and if the separate limbs are hurt robin
is hurt too
following robin and her sexy body parts
we have mr 3
and his dorudoru aka waxwax fruit he is
pretty much a candle human
this ability lets him create and control
a lot of wax and it even produces a
flame on top of his head
as if he were really a candle unlike a
logia user mr 3 cannot turn his whole
body into wax
the wax can be molded as the user wishes
the wax will solidify and become as
strong as steel
obviously because it's wax this power
does not play well with fire
after the candle human we got tin plate
waffle
the former monarch of the drum kingdom
he possesses the baku baku no me
aka the munch munch fruit this fruit
lets its user become an eating machine
the munch munch fruit user can open
their mouth extremely wide and eat
things that would not normally be
possible for humans to eat
even toxic things this dude is an actual
sword eater
no magic trick involved and he can even
eat cannons and houses
he can also manifest the things he eats
in creative ways for instance he can
even turn his body into a fortress that
shoots cannons
although he's often used for comedic
effect wapol's abilities are definitely
powerful the only problem is he
constantly has the munchies
after the ultimate eater we have bentham
of the wild aka mr two bunkurei
and his money money aka clone clone
fruit even though they started out as
enemies
bentham and luffy have since become
friends
not only that bentham has proven to be
an insanely good friend he
sacrificed himself repeatedly for luffy
including an
impel down which was touching af the
user of the clone clone fruit can
perfectly copy someone's face and body
after they touch that person's face with
their right hand
the user's clothes don't change though
so that could give them away
this ability is great if you want to
trick people into thinking you are
someone else
but it is not very useful in a
one-on-one fight before bentham
kurozumi higurashi a major supporter of
orochi
possessed the devil fruit power we just
talked about mr two so let's turn
to mr one next aka the killer das
bones this guy was considered to be the
strongest fighter of baroque works aside
from crocodile himself mr one eight the
super super no me aka the dice dice
fruit he's known as a full body bladed
human
this fruit allows the user to create
strong blades from any part of their
body
as mr one points out normal slashing and
hacking have no effect on him
but attacks that can cut through steel
can cut through him
for all of these reasons he was a great
person to match up against arzoro
after the sword human we have poison
spider zala aka miss doublefinger and
her togetogenomi
aka spike spike fruit as the name of the
fruit suggests
its user can produce spikes from their
body these spikes can be long and sharp
and are strong enough to break through
rock walls there is even a move called
spike you puncture
aka spike spike doping that greatly
increases the power of her arms
allowing her to punch through stone with
no problem she can also become a giant
rolling ball of spikes
like a deadlier sonic the hedgehog
another fun thing that miss double
finger can do is walk on the ceiling by
producing spikes on the bottom of her
feet
all in all it's definitely an awesome
power after spiky girl we have
black cage hina the marine officer and
the possessor of the oriori no me aka
cage cage fruit
everything that passes through hina's
body becomes bound by a strong
metal-like material
alternatively she can produce a giant
moving cage
and if anyone touches that they'll get
entangled and bound too
it's a great power for capturing people
alive next we have bellamy
the hyena the former captain of the
bellamy pirates and don quijote
underling he possesses the bonnet
bananomi aka the spring spring fruit
which lets him turn his limbs into
springs for instance he can turn his
legs into springs
in order to dramatically increase the
speed reach and strength of his attacks
the surface that bellamy uses to jump
off of can suffer extreme damage he's
like the human version of the slinky
spring toys we used to play with as kids
but of course
he's a bit deadlier after the slinky
spring man we have the very cool
don quijote doflamingo the former
captain of the don quixote pirates and
his itoito no me aka string string fruit
this fruit is one of the most versatile
and could definitely have its own
dedicated video
but let's mention some highlights the
user can produce strings from their body
that can attach to people surfaces or
even clouds
the strings can be used to control
people as if they were puppets
and they can potentially cut through
them doflamingo's strings are strong and
sharp enough to cut through bone
though flamingo can even use the strings
to perform internal surgery on himself
and he can use clouds to move through
the air he's like a deadlier and more
fashion conscious spider-man he can even
produce a giant barrier
around an island using his razor-sharp
strings the barrier can be made to close
in on itself and slice everything in its
way this move can completely destroy an
entire island the strings are even
trickier because they are so
thin they are often difficult to see
with the human eye
one drawback to this otherwise very very
op power
is that doflamingo has to remain
conscious or his
strings will disappear next let's look
at foxy
captain of the foxy pirates and his
noronoro no me aka slow slow fruit
this is a very fun power he can release
norma
photons that will slow down any object
or person they touch for 30 seconds
these norma photons are released in the
form of light beams so they can be
reflected by mirrors
if an opponent takes hits while they're
affected by the beam
the hits will pile up and when the 30
seconds are up they'll take the damage
and the kinetic force of all the blows
at once
a drawback is that the user can also be
affected by their own beams so the power
can potentially be used against them
next up we have bluno and assassin of
cp9 and his do adora no me
aka door door fruit this fruit lets the
user create doors
on solid surfaces so that they can pass
through them
it doesn't matter how thick or strong
the surface is
other people can pass through these
doors as well he can create doors under
a person's feet to trap them the user
can also create a door
in the air that leads to a kind of
alternate dimension
he can move within this alternate
dimension undetected and seemingly
teleport across vast distances
lastly he can turn his opponent into a
door temporarily
to keep them from moving this guy would
definitely make the best
personal doorman ever next we have
khalifa
the only female member of cp9 and her
awa no me aka bubble bubble fruit she's
a soap person
who can create bubbles anywhere on her
body furthermore she has total control
of the bubbles produced by her body
the bubbles can not only wipe dirt away
but even someone's power
kalifa can make everything she touches
extremely smooth
she can even leave people in a shiny
smooth state that is difficult to fight
in
she can use her bubbles to create a bar
of soap around her in order to protect
herself from enemy attacks
overall it's a very useful power but its
drawback is that something as common as
water
is its weakness water will wash away the
bubbles and return her smoothened
victims
back to normal like nami i also wouldn't
mind having khalifa as my personal
secretary
next we have captain very good one of
the marines who attacked the straw hats
during the enemy's lobby buster call
the dude has an afro and x-shaped scar
and a marine tattoo across his chin
talk about distinctive features he ate
the berry betty no me aka the berry
berry fruit
and became a grape human in a sense this
devil fruit was like the opposite of
buggy's devil fruit
although both allowed the user to
separate their body parts buggy is
immune to slashes
while captain very good seems to be
immune to blunt attacks
his body parts turn into many balls all
of which can float in the air
and can be used to attack the enemy
another captain who showed up for the
buster call
was captain shu he ate the sabi-sabi no
me aka the rustras fruit
captain shu can turn swords to rust
making them useless against him
in the anime he even starts turning
zorro into rust but zorro quickly goes
back to normal after captain shu
is no longer touching him thus in theory
given enough time captain xu might be
able to rust anything
except sea stone of course captain
shutting guru was another captain who
helped with the buster call you can
recognize him by his goggles
he ate the shari shari no me aka the
wheel wheel fruit
it appears he can turn different body
parts into wheels to increase his attack
power but the attacks do not seem to be
very effective against frankie's
metallic body parts
interestingly enough this devil fruit
power was not shown in the anime
and the captain attacks frankie with a
sword instead and that covers part one
of all paramecia users and their powers
explained if you want to see part two
make sure to smash that like button and
i will start working on it when we hit 5
000 likes
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell so you don't miss future one piece
videos
while you wait for the next one you can
check out our one piece playlist that
i'll link in the description
and at the end of this video a special
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help us survive youtube
issues and who help
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost
i want to thank our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alolan atem
the world
steelers the school bus tyson cuarino
a quiet respect and pate heffa
and i can't forget our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldras 50 dolla beat
anatoly kazatsky
alpha dio angel cruz team sparky 65
cricket xp rohan kapoor jessica maloney
emperor otaku timothy edward vargas jean
dark
joel stanton jcc walka very gucci and
jessica k lafond thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you